[Music]
I have been in a relationship with my
boyfriend for the past 5 years and
recently I gave him a marriage ultimatum
we're coming up to the end of that he is
telling you I've got other priorities
that are not you right now why do you
want to force him to marry
[Music]
you what up what up this is John with
the Dr John delone we show the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
and whatever else you got going on in
your live podcast ever ever um Kelly the
the producer who normally produces the
show is gone sitting at home staring off
into
space um actually she lives in a pretty
amazing trailer and she's just hanging
out in the trailer and she has like the
entire library of Days of Our Lives the
all 25 years of it and she is starting
with episode one and wearing her sweats
smoking menthols and she is not going to
get up from her seat until that series
is over and so Jenna's running the board
it's good to see you Jenna yeah it's
great to be here I can't we're shooting
this the day before Thanksgiving and
pretty much the entire company's not
here except for except for me and all of
us in here yeah Jenna has a has a like a
really phenomenal skill of making
everything everybody in the club about
her and so you're right but it's good to
see you yes this is going to be the best
show we've ever done because G McKell is
not here and we have a wild studio
audience that's just screaming and
yelling out there it's good to see
everybody uh if you want to be on this
show after that extraordinary
introduction give me a buzz at 1 1844
3291 leave a message and Jenna and Kelly
will check it out and get back to you
and see if we can get you in on the show
let's go out to bwood South Carolina and
talk to The Great and Wonderful Jasmine
what's up
Jasmine hi Dr John what's
happening uh not much it's a beautiful
day here today that's fantastic it's a
rainy gray sad cold day here which I
kind of love what's
up so I have been in a relationship with
my boyfriend for the past five years
okay and recently I gave him a marriage
ultimatum oh no you didn't did you
really I did how's that working out for
you well we're coming up to the end of
that I guess line and I'm honestly not
sure what to do how long how long did
you give him in your
ultimative three months and so how many
days are
left uh just over 30 I would I would I
would break up right now do you all live
together we do yeah I would say hey I'm
going to go ahead and move out this
weekend and I love you I'll probably
always love you and it's been so
great wow is that now what you thought I
was gonna
say no I honestly I was hoping you'd say
more but I honestly expected it here's
here's why I'm saying that number one I
dated my wife for five years off and on
we broke up a whole bunch we're in
college out of all that so the the time
doesn't bother me um some couples datay
for six years seven years some couples
stayed for three months right um that's
that's just life and I'm sure there's
some data there I really don't care to
read it it just is what it is but for
whatever reason and you've heard me say
this on the show a million times
behavior is a language and for whatever
reason he is telling you I've got other
priorities that are not you right
now and your priorities are security and
safety your priorities are maybe him
maybe they're a bigger Global picture
maybe they're hey my clock is ticking
hey there who knows what your priorities
are but they're different and my concern
about a marriage ultimatum either by
this date or I'm out is even if he says
okay will you marry me and you go oh my
gosh
yes he will always know he entered into
this thing this forever thing um being
dragg behind a car and you'll always
know I had to drag him into this and I
just worry about the the
longterm how often that resurfaces I
didn't even want to do this you force
this is this how you're going to handle
all of our problems um it just creates
Downstream ripples that I don't even
know if you can see them yet so tell me
tell me tell me about this guy why do
you want to marry
him or another question why do you want
to force him to marry
you honestly he's a great guy he um he's
a great dad to my kids um he's not their
biological dad but he's been there for
the Last 5
Years um and okay you just gave me two
things that have nothing to do with how
well yall work together romantically and
how yall are building a life together
that is true so give me that
info honestly we're struggling on that
info no tell me no way really and I'm
not laughing at you I'm laughing with
you of course you're struggling tell me
about
it we're struggling um the communication
isn't like it used to be we're not
communicating much at all we're mostly
talking in regards to the kids and
nothing more honestly at this point
right um Intimacy in all forms or have
been out the window okay yeah we're
we're not in the best of place and so
what about this is marriage going to
solve
I don't honestly I'm not sure I don't I
don't think it will solve anything I
think in the back of my mind that was my
way of getting an out which sounds
horrible now that I say it out loud
getting out of this
relationship yeah oh sweetheart tell me
tell me more about
that I love him dearly I just don't see
how it can be fixed at this point and I
figured well maybe if I throw marriage
out there and I give him this ultimatum
and he doesn't you know come on board
then I'll say well you are the reason
why
man that's that's I I I'm I'm giving you
high five for the courage to say that
out loud most people would cower behind
dishonesty there and you're not you're a
person of Integrity even though you're
doing a kind of a shady thing you're a
person of Integrity while you're doing
it right um why don't you believe enough
in yourself to call
it because of my
kids
so you want to be able to C to
manufacture a story that hey honey hey
kids he left us just like your dad
did no I I don't I you're right I need
to have the courage to say something and
I feel like I've been telling him over
the years for the last honestly two
years that I've been unhappy that we
need to talk more that we need to try
counseling and he just doesn't seem
receptive he keeps telling me how
important work is and other things
around the house are and I'm like we
don't even go on dates like what's going
on what happened with your your
children's
father uh so my first husband is my is
my oldest's father um he was very
abusive so that relationship didn't
work and my daughter's father was just
never in the picture okay so you have
two kids
yes are you sick of are you cuz you've
been alone
twice and with different relationships
and a child and you've also been alone
for a couple of years inside of this
relationship are you sick of being
alone I think so yeah I'm almost sick of
it for you I can't it's not my job I
can't do that for you but I'm almost I'm
heartbroken for
you are you scared to be a single mom
with two kids
again definitely tell me about that it
was it was my biggest fear when I had my
daughter and I didn't expect that I
would be a single mom of two by myself
and when it happened it was just like
okay you know what let's swallow this
pill and move on and handle it and it
just happens to be that I met him five
months in after my daughter was born so
five months into being the single mom of
two I met him and it's like I said it's
it's been a great relationship up until
a certain
point and I I don't know how to fix it
or what to do to nudge it over in the
right direction has it been a great
relationship up until two years ago or
was
it did it begin in chaos and it provided
you a like a a life raft in a Raging
Sea and no it was good I wouldn't say
that I would say it was good I was you
know doing my own thing I had just
bought a house I was living in a new
state everything was fresh and going
well between me and my kids the school
was going good like I had
this this pretty settled life and
everything was okay and I just kind of
met him and things blossomed then I sold
my house I moved to a new state to be
closer and you know it just it took a
while I felt like throughout our
relationship everything was kind of done
on his terms and the more that happened
the more resentment kind of build it up
there you
go how long's I've been building for a
long a long time I bet huh it's cuz
listen when you when you when when you
hear this when it comes out I want you
to pay special attention to that last
maybe minute and a
half when you told me about having your
second kid and buying a house and school
was settled your whole voice
changes you remember Walking Tall even
though you are in a really difficult
situation financially have two little
kids you got no
help and then when you start talking
about I sold my house I moved to a new
state everything in your vocal tone
changes as though you're getting dragged
back
underwater and then it didn't surprise
me at all real quick you mentioned then
the resentment starts
building that you're basically you and
your two kids are a a cog in his
life does that feel does that feel
right
yeah and here's the thing I I I I
wouldn't do this job I wouldn't work
with married couples behind closed doors
I wouldn't do that if I didn't think
there was always a possibility a
chance back not not back a chance
forward a chance to build something
new but it sounds to me like you've been
trying to do that for a long time and he
just has no interest in it and I mean to
be frank why would he you're probably
not going
anywhere
right yeah my my friends keep saying the
same thing they've been saying the same
thing for the last two years you're
probably not going anywhere you've been
saying you're going to go and you're
still here yeah you use that threat so
many times when you said you got 90 days
to marry me or I'm out he's like okay
sure you want Arby's like you're like
like
okay
so what happens tonight if you sat down
and said hey I think we're
done I love you you've been so great to
my kids Last 5 Years you're really the
dad that they
know and we met in a really vulnerable
moment for me and a vulnerable season
for me and I'm so grateful that you were
there for me but you don't love me you
don't want to be
married what do you say as adults we
call
this and we'll figure out the finances
and I'll figure out what to do and we'll
go from
there because you'll have a legal claim
to some of the house you have a legal
claim to some of the assets and all that
stuff y'all can be adults about it and
split it up because you're not even
married or you can go to court and this
whole thing is going to be a
nightmare what does he say if you say
that does he sound relieved do you sound
relieved I think I'll sound relieved and
he'll sound kind of of like what what's
been going on like he's been out of the
loop in a sense but he hasn't
been would there be a possibility that
you could walk back like hey I've asked
you to go to counseling nine times in
the last two
years I even concocted a story that said
I was breaking up with you if you didn't
marry me and now we're a month out like
what like I'm we're
done we haven't held hands in two years
we haven't been on a date in three
years I have no friends we don't have
couples over we don't see what I'm
saying like is there a way just to kind
of lay out the data
there yeah there
is so what's your
reluctance do you have a job I do you
make good
money I do so financially you can walk
away you can go get an apartment today
take two
kids or after Thanksgiving you can take
your two kids you can do that huh but
it's my house so he'd be the one moving
out that's what I'm talking
about so you can give him 30 days
yeah see I mean you see what I'm
saying no you're absolutely right what's
the hesitation if you gave me any like
any spark in the darkness that he wants
to work on this that he's that that
y'all have just come to an impass you're
not communicating well intimacy life's
over over you want some stability he's
out just doing his thing whatever you're
tired of being a girlfriend what if you
told me that there's any sort of Hope
there I'd be all in all
in but it sounds like you broke up with
him two years ago and you just lived in
the same house with
him and then you're trying to at the
very end get him to break up with you so
you can feel a little bit self-righteous
in a way that's cruel it's cruel to your
kids it's cruel to him and more
important it's cruel to you
I just think you're worth more than that
I think if this relationship's over it
needs an adult to say hey I'm just going
to call what
is there's always a doctor it has to be
the doctor that that comes into an
emergency room when a patient has passed
everybody's been working everybody's
sweating everybody sometimes there tears
in people's eyes there's there's gauze
everywhere there's blood everywhere
there's instruments everywhere it's a
doctor's job to come in and call
it time of death is official at this
time and if that's where you are be the
adult here clearly you're you you're an
adult in other places cuz you're a mom
two kids you're a good professional
where you make good money like I think
it's
time and maybe he looks at you and says
I'll do anything if he does great you
can say cool we got to build something
completely new starting
today I hope that's the case I really do
thanks for the call
Jasmine my best the best the best of
luck to you I'd love to know how that
conversation goes if you'll holler back
at us and let us know we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone this time of year
there can be a lot of anxiety and a lot
of drama but it can also be great but it
can also be a mix of everything right
especially when it comes to giving gifts
maybe your family makes super thoughtful
handmade things or they expect you to
spend a million dollars or maybe you
just like experiencing time together or
pick up random gift cards last minute
things like gift giving can make us
bananas so no matter how hectic it gets
especially around
giftgiving remember to take care of
yourself whether it's going easier on
yourself during tough moments or having
to say hey we don't have enough money to
buy all these gifts or treating yourself
to a Day of Silence remember to give
yourself some love this holiday season
and if things get too heavy if thinking
about dealing with your family and all
of the drug drama gets to be too much
give better help a try better help is
flexible because it's online so it can
fit into your busy holiday schedule just
fill out a short questionnaire to get
match with the licensed therapist and
you can switch therapist at any time for
no extra charge in this season of Chaos
in love and sadness and all of it rolled
up to one give yourself what you need
with better help visit betterhelp.com
dealone toay to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com all right we're back let's go out
to Fort Collins Colorado and talk to
Kate what's up
Kate Hi how are you I I'm great I'm my
I'm a lot sorry I probably came on a
little bit strong there how are
you I'm good a little under the weather
so bear with my rough voice you sounded
like you're a couple margaritas into the
morning morning so that's good I wish I
wish what's
up so I emailed you last week asking how
I can get my mom to stop sending us
crappy
gifts I'm not like I'm I'm laughing at
you and with you both okay tell me about
this what kind of crappy gifts it is
kind of funny but it's been going on my
whole life John
um so she will randomly send you know
things that are wrapped these are gifts
this is like a Christmas or a
birthday um I think I even mentioned I
one time got a used bar of soap we have
the same monogram so um you know belts
that she pulled out out of her husband's
closet for my
ex-husband um just really random stuff
and it has always sent the message to me
that I'm not
worth while I'm not worth her time her
effort her money and it's crazy how much
of a pervasive problem this has been in
our relationship I had to cut her out of
my life for a few years and um recently
brought her back in and I let her come
to our house I've got four kids and she
wanted to come watch my son play
football and I was like all right we
need to do some maintenance beforehand
and we worked through some things I've
been in
therapy part of her visitation I was
like please do not bring anything with
you she's like I've got some old pants
I've outgrown I'm like no no you know
thank you I'll I'll look at him when I
come to to visit you well she still
proceeded to bring all kinds of stuff
she left and then she started mailing
things to me and John it it just sent me
over the edge I was so so angry when she
sent this last package it was like
broken jewelry and you know stuff I
would never wear and I have I've asked
her I've said if you insist on getting
us gifts just get us gift cards or just
don't give us anything at all and you
know I don't want to come across as
ungrateful but truly I'd rather just not
have anything I just don't know how to
handle
it so like in my
mind I I instantly go to what seems like
a parallel that I know is not but I it
seems like a parallel which is like junk
mail we're going to be in your area
doing gutters and we'd love to do your
gutters for 10% Like and that stuff
never even enters my house it just goes
straight from my mailbox into the trash
can into the recycle bin whatever so
there has to be something deeper you
mentioned earlier you created a story
around these
gifts that this that the story you
created for yourself around these gifts
is my mom thinks so little of
me that this is what she thinks I'm
worth where does that story come from
well she's that's 100% true
how you know I go ahead I'm sorry well
what's the other side of and I always
try to think up an alternative story
that that might counter what I my the
pervasive story to have in my head is
and what if she stole her husband's
favorite belt because he loved it so
much and was like I'm gonna give this to
her husband like is there a chance that
she loves this stuff so much or she just
is she have mental health diagnos
diagnosis like what's this it's sounds
pathological she can't stop
I know um yeah I mean the reason that I
gave our relationship almost a fiveyear
break was it was my birthday and she
gave me this necklace and as she you
know if she had not said anything I
probably wouldn't have received it the
way that I did but she was like it's I
know you don't like blue and I know you
don't like silver but it was really
expensive and and it wasn't I took it
back and was able to exchange it for a
tube of
mascara um you know I I don't know what
it is is I don't know if she's just like
I have to show up with something so I've
got to you know do this but you know
I've I've been my therapist said maybe
you could just ship it back to her which
requires you know work on my part yeah I
don't want to do chores for something
but I but but here's the thing I got a
buddy and he believes it is wholly
inhospitable to show up to an invitation
to somebody's house even if it's just
like hey come on over we're fill in the
blank we're watching the game or come on
over he cannot like psychologically
enter into somebody's home without a
welcome gift of some sort and he has
shown up to my house with like ends of
mosquite wood like in a bag that go in a
grill and it would never occur to me to
bring so I I but I always look past it
to this is his small wpes in um thanks
for having me
over and I guess in my head there's no
skin off of it but I haven't created a
story around it so I guess the question
I would ask you is what's more important
your relationship with your mom or the
story cuz the the things that she's
given you are
benign unless it is her subtly and with
a great amount of like claw digging like
just taking a dig this is her way of
flipping you off and being able to go
what
what that's how it feels but I is it I'm
trying to air that she loves me and that
you know CU I would never engage in that
Behavior with my own children of course
and yeah and so let's let's road test
it like imagine you've written that on a
note card my mom sends me gifts in the
form like broken jewelry and whatever
dolls with missing eyeballs and she
gives me gifts that she says out loud I
know you're not going to like this but
wow I spent a bunch of money on it put
that on a note card an imaginary note
card and hold it as far away as you can
like put your arm away out there and
road test it read that is that story
true is it true I don't care how it
feels I guess is that story
true yeah it is okay then you've
answered your question and I think the
Humane thing to do is the the the way
that you don't lose your humanity is you
continue to treat somebody with dignity
or respect even if they don't offer you
the same I'm a big believer in this I
think it would heal of our world but you
tell her with all dignity and respect
hey I've asked you multiple times since
we're back together we're back in each
other's lives to not bring gifts and you
seem unable to not do
that I'm going to have to for my sake
for my kids sake I'm going to have to um
put up some pretty significant
boundaries let that be that if you ghost
here I think that's
cruel and if you if you mail it back I
that just feels Petty to me to me I
don't want to badmouth your counsel it
just feels like I'll show you like yeah
like that just feels like I'm not going
to solm
anything I think you're right back throw
it in the trash I mean you can you're
still in the
trash I'd always have that fear that she
dropped a diamond ring in there or
something but I mean believe me we think
that every time every time everyone's
hopes gets up and we're 100% always
disappointed so but I like where you're
saying just like test it if it's true
and then the boundary is no more yeah if
it's true it's true I often I'm trying
to think of something I'll I'll I've
used this this example before but my
wife and I will have a conversation
about hey you're like wet towels on the
floor and and can you please that like
makes me crazy I don't know why it just
does and then I walk in the next day and
that wet towels on the floor and
instantly I create a story about oh dude
she is flipping me off she knows I I was
vulnerable I told her it's a big deal to
me and she just Dr DRT it here on
purpose I can make that story up and
then when I think of that story in
context with the extraordinary woman
that I married who spends most of her
life making sure that I know I'm loved
and that my life runs like in any shape
former
fashion then I can make up another story
which is my God what had to happen
today right after we just talked about
this that there's another towel
here this house must have got off the
rails my kids must have been trying to
set things on fire and bury the dog in
the yard and barbecue like the neighbors
like pet like what it must have been so
bananas here and I pick up the towel and
I go on about my day see what I'm saying
so if you look at that and go no no no
this was on purpose she's just trying to
she's trying to rub salt in a pretty
deep
wound cool you've got your answer and
it's hard and it's heartbreaking you'll
have to grieve the fact that your mom
would rather flip you off than honor you
you and your kids I can't think of a
thing that would be worse than
that yeah it's hard and that's where
I've struggled with just it's not really
about the gifts John I know my life
because she spits on your boundaries bad
when I'm around her yeah yeah she spits
on your boundaries and my guess is this
isn't the only thing she violates oh
dear no no so I think what you need to
to make peace with is entering into a
season of
grief because either your mom is like
wholly unwell and unwilling to go get
well or your mom enjoys watching you
squirm
yeah okay and I hate that for you I wish
that wasn't the case I don't think
anybody should have to deal with that
with their
mom same yeah
right yeah I hate it for you but I think
it's right if you can hold that in an
imaginary note chord or if you're a
gangster write in a real not card hold
it out in front of you is this
true did that guy really cut me off in
traffic because he's just doing drugs
and wants to see us all die
or did he cut me off in traffic because
he's trying his best to get to the
hospital for his wife dies I get to pick
whichever one of those stories but if
you know one to be true if he flips you
off all the way over and he's eyeballing
you and he cuts you off you know that
story is
true if your mom keeps doing it Mom do
not send stuff okay okay she shows up
with a bunch of stuff and goes I know
you won't even like this one
yeah unfortunately sounds like Mom may
be opting out of your relationship I'm
sorry especially especially after you
tried let her back in right here during
the holiday
season spend some time in grief and
please please please continue to honor
your mother not by letting her run all
over your family and hurt you and your
kids honor your mom by being honest
telling her the truth and putting up
very very firm boundaries that are going
to
hold then maybe you sit down up against
one of those boundaries and just weep
it's not supposed to be this way thanks
for your call Kate we'll be right
back if you've listened to my show any
amount of time you've definitely heard
me talk about thorn thorn is an
incredible supplement company that makes
what I think are the best supplements in
the game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcast
are just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming they the next
great thing for all sorts of ailments
almost all of those claims and products
are either lying not good products are
just a waste of your money Thorn is one
of the very few supplement companies
that make Pure Clean tested and backed
by science supplements no fluff no
gimmicks no nonsense Thorn is what I
take personally and it's what I give to
my kids and make no mistake supplements
of this quality cost more than the
nonsense you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thorne for an incredible
25% off discount for our delone show
listeners go to thorne.com
youdon choose what you want add it to
your cart create an account and when you
check out 25% off will be knocked off of
the entire order and here's the best
part that discount sticks around for
Life go to thorne.com thelet
youone check it out
let's go out to Glendale Arizona and
talk to Kylie what's up
Kylie hi Dr John thank you so much for
taking my call of course what's
up uh not too much just kind of been
anticipating this and I'm kind of
nervous so well just pull up a seat and
grab some nachos and we can hang out
it's all good what's up sounds good um
so my original question that I sent in
was oh along the lines of how can I
embrace and learn to appreciate my body
during
pregnancy um I've struggled with poor
body image and low self-esteem for the
majority of my life and now it seems to
be more
prevalent and I I don't know if you need
background information I feel like it's
pretty straightforward but yeah they it
always feels that way and it never is
um who told you you're not
beautiful I think I just lived my life
really comparing myself to a lot of
people starting at a young age did
somebody teach you
that you know I don't know I I feel like
it
was I don't know I feel like I'm just
overly critical and I'm the hardest
critic on myself and I know but who
taught you that Kylie why are you
nervous to
say often people who are very very
self-critical we're also in charge of
other people's emotions all the time
yeah whose emotions were you in charge
of all the
time I
mean it's say
it I I'm just the oldest of four and so
I feel like it was kind of my job to be
the example to my siblings
and um you can't say you can't say I I
I'm sorry I keep interrupting I know I'm
about that you can't even say Mom and
Dad can you I can't cuz it just I mean
they did so much for me growing up
and I really feel like I had a good
childhood but it's just it's been really
prevalent lately just how critical I am
yeah so I'm going to tell you right now
one of the keys
to being well moving
forward is both and
okay okay both
and that's going to be your Guiding
Light in the dark moving
forward okay your mom and dad were
amazing and they were also really really
hard on
you and your mom and dad provided you
with meals and a home and college and
all this
stuff and you also had to dance monkey
dance
and you knew if I say this dad's going
to get real pissed off and if I do this
mom loses her cool and dad looks at you
and goes why'd you make mom mad you've
been in charge of their emotions
forever yeah I think it was hard my dad
worked out of town a lot while I was
growing
up and so I've just gone back and kind
of thought like I just had to kind of be
okay as the oldest and were you your
mom's best friend make things work um
I wouldn't say that but as I got older I
feel like you know I just had to kind of
pick up the slack and help out around
the house
more oh sweetheart you're so
awesome all right I'm gonna give as we
talk I'm gonna give you like some
homework assignments will you commit to
doing them yes okay one of the
assignments is I want you to and this is
going to sound so cheesy and dumb
okay okay I want you to draw a picture
and if you have crayons or map pencils
in your house I want you to use
color okay and there's a specific reason
I won't get all nerdy out but there's a
reason I want you to draw as Vivid a
picture as possible of you at
12 okay
okay and I want you to be very
intentional about the things you were
self-conscious of in your body at 12
okay you're too flatchested you were too
busty for a 12-year-old for all your
friends you you're you had too big a
tummy or you were too tall and skinny
whatever the things were that you knew
you were out of bounds on
okay okay and
then with that piece of with that
picture in front of you I want you to do
a free right for 15 minutes I want you
to set a
clock and I want you to write
12-year-old a
letter okay and I wanted to start with
DK KY I'm so so proud of
you and I can't
believe you were worried about Fillin
the blank can be very
specific and do you remember that time
mom commented on this or the boy on the
bus commented about this or you had a
boyfriend and he commented about
that
okay okay and if you really commit to it
my guess
is there'll be a crack in the facade
you've built because your facade is
incredible you're real
good you've been protecting people for a
long time okay all right so that's step
one all right okay step two is this is
this your first baby first
pregnancy yes and I think that's what
I've struggled with is excuse me my
husband and I we got pregnant quickly
like um and I think I didn't really
mentally prepare myself for all of the
changes and I don't know if you ever can
be mentally prepared but it's just like
not only is pregnancy been hard
physically it's just like the mental
toll of it is also like another level
that I haven't
experienced
so is there a chance that the thing that
haunted you as a 12 and 15 and 17 and 19
and 20 year
old when everything just feels too much
that's what your
body automatically defaults to to just
Loop and and cycle on
that that place where you're not enough
you're not enough you're not enough
you're not
enough yeah and it's just so frustrating
because I know I am but I feel like I've
just grown up with that cycle that it's
just like no matter what I tell myself
it's like oh but you know you really
you're just saying that to yourself you
know it can't be all true like I know
I'm loved I know I'm valued and
cherished but oh there's no question are
so powerful you know yeah there's no
question the only person that doesn't
believe that is is you yeah everybody
around you can tell you that your
husband loves you doesn't he yes he's
very good to me probably in a kind of a
groy way
right
yeah he's he's been the best and just so
supportive through this too have you
looked at him sometimes and not said
anything but in your mind thought you're
crazy yeah yeah and he's watching you is
how far along are you um 14 weeks okay
so you haven't seen a drastic change
physically um no what I what I think
what kind of scared me and kind of
initiated this call was I was really
sick my first trimester and actually
between my first and second appointment
lost quite a bit of weight and it just
scared me because initially when I knew
how much weight I lost I was like oh
that's good like I'm losing weight this
is great but then I had to rethink it
and say no like I have another life that
I'm in charge of now that needs
nourishment and you know this is not
good so I think that's what like I just
don't want to have that mindset you know
it's not a mindset how long have you
struggled with
anxiety um you know I've always felt
like I'm a pretty even mellow go with
the flow person but no Kylie no you
haven't I know you haven't but then when
I think about it it's like I am
sometimes not okay like how I deal with
things I just would rather shut down
than like actually deal with stuff and I
really do think I am anxious and it's
hard you know it's hard to manage and
even I don't know it's been a hard
wakeup call for me okay
so I want you for the first time in your
life to consider that the anxiety that
you feel and by the way I believe with
all my guts and intellect that anxiety
and depression are on the same trend
line okay and your body will try to get
your attention and try to get your
attention and try to get your attention
and it we'll just shut the system
down yeah and does that ring true with
you yeah and I think I just you know try
and shove it down and that's right
because you had to you had to yeah you
basically had a single mom with a drop
in dad and you had three or four little
ones that you were in charge of and you
were in charge of mom and I know you're
like well it was all perfect it wasn't
you know it I know it but you can deal
with that later and then so your body
has been scanning the environment 247
rapid ly and with great intensity for
your whole
life yeah and you may have gotten some
exhale when you found this knuckleheaded
cute boy who said I'll love you forever
and ever and you're like
wooo and then you finally find not not a
voice but you find his presence and he's
close and he's connected and he's strong
and he listens to you and he holds you
and your body maybe for the first time
in your life starts to go ah
and then damn it you're pregnant right
right after
that and then it's like oh my gosh
what's gonna happen what if there's war
what if climate change is real what if
this what if we're going to have any
money we're not going to be able to go
to college is college is still going to
be here and and it just keeps going
right yes yeah never ending Loop
honestly I want you to consider
something okay what if your body's
working
perfectly okay okay what if it's working
for you
what if it is a a mix of experiences
you've had plus genetics plus all these
things that when it sounds the alarms
this is what it feels like and you've
heard me say this a million times on the
show if your a smoke detector goes off
in your kitchen it's not the smoke
detector that's the problem it's the
fire that's the
problem and so it may be that you need
to go have go on an expedition a loving
one a curious one not a judgmental one a
huh I wonder why that thing's going off
not a ah it's going off ah I got to
shove it all down until the system
collapses no let's just go look and
see okay okay your body is growing a
human yeah your body is loved by some
boy
G right do you
work I do okay I don't mean this in a
gross way or like in a pervy way but
your body is loved by your workplace
they love that you show up and that you
accomplish a goal and serve customers
and take care of people right yeah and I
can just tell by be on the phone are you
a person that like brings a meal if
somebody's
sick yes I I try to be that I know you
are I can tell by the way you talk you
are and you laugh at jokes that aren't
even that funny you probably laugh kind
of loud to help people out is that you
yes okay here's what I want I want you
to treat like
that
okay and I wish there was another way
word I could give you than one I'm about
to tell you okay you simply have to
practice believing that Kylie is worth
laughing at her jokes
too you have to believe that Kylie was
worth that boy that grown man telling
God and his family and your family and
you I do
forever come what comes I'll be right
here yeah you see what I'm saying and
the only way you can do that is you got
to practice it and that's a terrible
word I know it's not romantic there's
nothing in the in Hollywood about
practicing you know like getting back in
touch with yourself
right yeah I totally agree with that so
here's how we're gonna do that okay how
old are you I'm 23 all right I'm going
to get things all kind of weird you
ready okay yeah I I want you to sit down
with yourself first and then you're
probably going have to fill in some gaps
with your husband and tell him this is
delon's weird dumb idea and I said I
would do it okay okay I told him and all
21 of his listeners this that he's that
we're gonna do this okay okay I want you
to write down 23
things that that make Kylie one of the
most remarkable lovable people on the
planet
okay that's so hard it's not it's not
it's
not I'm totally lying it's the worst it
is the worst it is so
hard I don't know if the episode has
aired yet but I talked about this
earlier um after doing some pretty hard
trauma work um with a counselor and
working through some things she finally
nailed
me and she was talking about the ticker
tape that is my life and that ticker
tape you know that little thing that
runs underneath the the stock market on
under the news channels that's always
just going or under ESPN she said your
ticker tape just says I
suck I'm the worst all the
time yeah and so she made me ball up my
fist and put it in my chest and I have
to look in the mirror and say the words
I love this
guy and this guy's worth being loved
it's just a thing I repeat
now and I think every you created a a
Persona that makes you so
lovable as a strange protective measure
because you don't buy
it yeah I I feel like that's really
ringing true
okay somebody somewhere told you that
you're worth about what you can how many
kids you can keep
quiet somebody told you that you're
lovable when the report card looks right
or when your body looks right or if your
nose is just perfect or if your bra
isn't weird like somebody told you those
things and you begin to scan the world
for them to make sure they were
true yeah and so most people want to go
fix the body image thing way way down
river I want you to go up
River okay okay because I mean let's
like the objective criteria here you're
losing weight during a pregnancy your
body's growing a human is your baby it
was your was your one try was your
checkup
good yeah I'm really grateful everything
has been normal and I've been better
since that first initial check-in um his
husband being weird and not wanting to
hold your hand and being all like uh can
I just look at Tik Tok no he's he's been
really helpful and honestly yeah I
couldn't ask for a better partner right
now he's super supportive I don't know
how some people go through this alone
yeah it's it's it's tough but here's the
deal the
data
truth is that you're loved
immensely that your body's working
great yeah and by the way when you first
bear the weight of the responsibility of
another life of course your body's going
to be nervous about what happens in the
future of course it would be you'd be
crazy if you weren't you know what I
mean yes you're bringing a human and if
you've made the cardinal sin of Googling
motherhood stuff oh God don't do that
please don't do that you're GNA go mad
yeah there's a whole ecosystem out there
that's designed for one thing to make
you feel guilty and unstable as a as a
about to be new mom and then a new mom
because if you feel guilty and unstable
you'll buy a bunch of
crap I mean that's what it comes down to
you're not doing this right you're not
doing this right win you know
with how the motherhood is these days
designed to be it's just really
confusing but there's a great
documentary I watched it was years ago
but it was powerful I don't know if it
holds up but it was called The Business
of Being
Born um and I don't even know where it
would show I think I saw it on Netflix
back in the day but I don't know where
it is but it just walked through like
this thing that is so innate to The
Human Experience over gajillions of
years like in the ' 50s became this
really
robust uh medical procedure this surgery
that um had to come with like all the
right rattles in strollers and if you
don't have a million dollars your baby's
G dude madness madness madness of course
there's medical intervention that's
needed and all that yeah but at least at
the time when you talk about uh I can go
all down a rabbit hole on that one but
just looking at the data and again this
may be eight or nine or 10 years old but
the data on when C-sections are
performed are most often performed at um
doctor shift changes they want to go
home so it's wild but anyway all I I
tell you this sounds like everything's
working perfectly so it sounds like the
data is right and it sounds like we need
to I'm G say this going to sound so
cheesy and I get it we need to fall in
love with
Kylie what an amazing mom she's gonna be
what an incredible wife she already is
what a great big sister she's always
been what an extraordinary employee what
a
great
woman and I know that sounds bananis and
so we're going to practice it so those
things you're going to write them down
every single day of your life for 30
days okay I want you to write them down
and I want you to pause between each one
so it might take you 10 or 15 minutes to
write them all the way
down but I Kylie shows
up KY K is a person who tells the truth
and always keeps her word kylie seeks
out people who are uncomfortable and
makes sure that they're doing
okay Kylie laughs at dumb jokes just so
people don't feel
embarrassed Kylie answers her mom's
phone calls all the freaking time even
though it stresses her out right all
these things 23 of them we're going to
write them down every day for 30 days
and then I want you to make a fist and I
want you to put it right in your chest
and I want you to look in the mirror
and say I love this
woman okay and when you do it I want you
to feel your shoulders tense up because
they're going to and I want you to
consciously drop them and say it again I
love this woman she's
good and then by the way your body's
about to do some crazy stuff right yeah
yeah cool we're GNA roll with
it we're going to roll with it that's
that's the part twoo is like like
there's no control over it which like
you said it's like it's amazing and it's
beautiful but it's just it's hey what
you're talking about you just gave me
you're talking about anxiety I can't
control it exactly exactly that's what
opening your hands up and choosing to
ride down the river instead of using
every ounce of everything to trying to
swim up River you're pregnant sister
you're having a baby you're heading down
the river now open your hands up hold
your husband's hand yall are in this
together I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life my number
one bestselling book and I want you and
your husband to use that as a road map
for the next I don't know however many
weeks 30 weeks I don't remember how many
weeks you said but and then the first
year of of the baby's life and then the
second year and your marriage is going
to change dramatically and that's all
good you're going to be an incredible
mom you're you incred you are an
incredible
wife
and when it feels so heavy ride it down
and demand evidence is this true and
you're going to drop your shoulders and
smile and go that's not
true I love this
girl I'm a good mom I'm a good wife and
I'm worth being
loved congratulations Kylie we'll be
right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
delone.org all right as we wrap up
today's show with Jenna at the helm of
course she's going to send us all into
our Thanksgiving holiday which I think
when this comes out it'll be just before
the Christmas yeah a week out from
Christmas the Great and Powerful Taylor
Swift song's called you're losing Me
From the Vault what is the Vault the
vault is uh she released Midnight's the
album and then later she released the
song it's from the Vault it didn't get
released on the album initially it's
from The Vault tricky
tricky goes like this you say I don't
understand and I say I know you don't we
thought a cure would come through in
time now I fear it won't remember
looking at this room we loved it cuz of
the light now I just sit here in the
dark and wonder if it's time do I throw
out everything we built or keep it I'm
getting tired even for a phoenix always
rising from the ashes mending all her
gashes you might have just dealt the
final blow my gosh she it's so maddening
how good she is the idea that picture of
an exhausted Phoenix
goie she's so good love you guys
bye